knows full well what treasure lies in
the earth just like everyone else here
in parque de la papa
in this region at an elevation of four
thousand meters six communities work the
fields together just like the incas did
more than four thousand potato varieties
grow in peru but climate change could
reduce the number
some years it doesn't rain during the
rainy season
it's too dry
then it suddenly rains during the dry
season
here they use every type of potato
the compass gets sweeter as it's chewed
and provides a good harvest even if it
is infected with disease
the cachoonwa cachina is used to test
brides to be
if she peels the potato too slowly the
wedding's off
the variety is also of interest to the
international potato center in lima
for years they've been collecting as
many potato species as possible to store
them for the future
plant parts can survive for centuries in
liquid nitrogen
stored at minus 30 degrees celsius
potato seeds keep for decades
scientist john even beam examines plants
in the in vitro gene bank where they're
grown before replanting in the fields
and because over the centuries the
tubers from peru have become the world's
third most consumed food product the
scientists can also answer the question
what will people be eating in the future
the answer lies in the variety we're
prepared for every change whether from
pests or disease or climate change the
answer is stored here these potatoes
provide the crop yield we need the
resistance we need the nutritional value
and the necessary adaptability
the scientists in lima work closely
together with the farmers from the
parque de la papa in the mountains who
bring in different potato varieties
in turn the scientists give them tubers
and seeds free of disease and the
promise of a better harvest
once a year there's a big festival the
day of the potato
this year in the community of paru paro
just like centuries ago it's celebrated
with traditional music and dance
the festival gives thanks to pachamama
mother earth for all she's provided
each of the six communities brings
offerings
and what better way to celebrate the
potato than to eat it together